you say that you're going to do  everything that you can to reduce the  impact that high gas prices have on  americans  we're asking other countries to think  about maybe pumping more oil why not  just do it here  well to be very clear federal policies  are not  limiting the supplies of oil and gas to  the cut let me finish to the con let me  finish an executive order  halted new oil gas let me let me give  you let me give you the facts here and i  know that can be inconvenient but i  think they're important in this moment  there are 9 000 approved drilling  permits that are not being used so the  suggestion that we are not allowing  companies to drill is inaccurate  shinsaki blowing up on our very own  peter ducey and getting a little  defensive over exploding gas prices the  cost of a gallon is now over four  dollars nationally and the president's  plan to deal with it is to kiss up to  dictators instead of producing more oil  here at home